du 23 au 25 novembre l'organisation
policière internationale interpol tient
une assemblée générale en turquie pour
élire son nouveau président un nom a
filtré depuis quelques mois celui du
général émirati ahmed nasser al rahi si
inspecteur général au ministère de
l'intérieur dans son pays mais il est
accusé de toutes parts d'avoir orchestré
diverses répression et torture les
émirats sont régulièrement épinglées
pour leurs entorses aux droits de
l'homme comme le traitement
catastrophique des travailleurs migrants
qui composent 80% de la population des
émirats avec de nombreux cas d'
esclavage la liberté de la presse et
d'expression reste entravé il malgré
quelques réformes de façade la situation
est critique et en tant que haut gradé
ahmed nacera ici concernée est visé par
plusieurs plaintes en particulier celles
concernant les arrestations arbitraires
de deux ressortissants britanniques
leurs avocats roannais dixon a porté
plainte contre le général émirati fin
septembre à paris il a même demandé que
le général soit arrêté s'il pénétrait
sur le territoire français mathieu
hedges est un universitaire arrêté en
2018 il était suspecté d'être espions et
fut déclarée coupable il fut condamné à
la prison à vie avec isolement tortures
physiques psychologiques violent
cocktail de médicaments imposé à la clé
le britannique fut finalement gracié en
novembre 2018 après de fortes
mobilisations
aujourd'hui ils s'insurgent je n'arrive
pas à croire que près de trois ans après
ma libération je doive me rendre au
siège d'interpol pour leur demander de
ne pas élire au poste de président un
des hommes responsables de la torture
alyssa ahmad quant à lui fut arrêté abou
dhabi en janvier 2019 après avoir porté
un t-shirt supportant l'équipe du qatar
pays avec lequel les émirats était en
délicatesse allissa fût lui aussi
violemment battu le torse lacéré une
autre plainte fut également déposée en
juin par l'avocat william bourdon pour
tortures et actes de barbarie elle
concerne ahmed mansour un militant des
tenues aux émirats arabes unis en france
c'est le député du rhône hubert julien
laferrière qui mène la mobilisation
contre le général il a écrit à emmanuel
macron en juin une lettre cosignée par
35 parlementaires pour qu'ils bloquent
cette candidature problématique je
m'associe à ce communiqué de mes
collègues parlementaires allemands qui
eux aussi s'oppose à la candidature
d'ahmed al a réussi à la présidence
d'interpol accusé de crimes de torture
ce candidat des émirats ne peut
prétendre à occuper une fonction aussi
éminente le noeud du problème loupé a
réalisé par abou dhabi sur
l'organisation policière internationale
car interpol est financé par la
souscription de ses 194 membres les
émirats arabes unis devrait s'acquitter
d'environ deux cent cinquante mille
euros par an or ils se sont engagés à
verser 50 millions d'euros en 2016 à ce
tarif-là pas étonnant qu'interpol en
face son favori pas surprenant que les
militants avocats et élus qui demandent
des explications aux officiels français
n'obtiennent pas de réponse d'autant que
les émirats sont aussi dans le top 5 des
principaux clients de la france en
matière de ventes d'armes entre 2010 et
2019 au delà des relations d'intérêt
mutuel avec les riches émirati un
problème est soulevé
l'instrumentalisation d'un terre-plein
par les pays autoritaires ainsi certains
abusent des notices rouges sorte de
mandats d'arrêt internationaux qui
permettent d'interpeller des
contrevenants hors de leurs frontières
nationales certains pays en maîtres de
nombreuses pour appréhender leurs
opposants politiques et les émirats font
partie des nations qui en abusent le
plus est d'ailleurs parfois pour des
délits mineurs comme des chèques sans
provision la coupe est donc suffisamment
pleines pour tenter de bouter le général
hors de l'organisation
mais apparemment les pétrodollars n'ont
pas d'odeur pour interpol